okay I had a lot of gunfire around me
all right that's because I already know
mark is a traitor
I do not do not do my work is uh markers
preparing he's a traitor
I am a diamond I am a traitor you know
what I'm gonna call it be a traitor I'm
mature I'll be a trader entrance seven
seconds
traitors five more I'll make a promise
if I'm the traitor I didn't know what
guys look I have no gun so therefore I'm
gonna do it don't watch me that's in
uh-huh uh I'm an innocent hey hey whoa
where he should shine watch it it was
not me it was not me it was brutally
Surgical again yeah oh yeah was - Lee I
see you look as I would I would betray
nicely if I was a traitor I would have
killed you then Spain think about it I'm
pretty sure this is very trader II hello
yeah what button again to exit the other
three thank you see okay hey hi hey
we're a whole string okay whisky I'm
holster yeah I'm all stressed associate
wrist between it's Alistar that's a nice
Bluetooth headset you have there that's
nice on YouTube oh my god oh my god is
it only two left and then there were two
I wonder who the traitor could be yeah
thank you it's mix I told you from the
beginning
shotguns good for long-range is it no no
not really
guy muck dammit but I can have a really
friendly trailer watch napalm at night
you might come back go back right
come come Park Mac is a traitor Lizzie
hey mom
I don't even have a gun get away from me
hi crazy duck don't know don't ever be
greedy
you all suck oh really oh really oh no
alright Rach no no poverty God eh I
didn't know you all hated me so much I
think we're even now mark I think we're
even although you did it much quicker
than I did thank you I pride myself in
being the fastest around uh-huh that's
what she said I don't think that's a
good thing you're so God are we really
foreign aids already gonna love you like
that yeah you all suck just saying that
right dog oh ow ow ow ow I'm then
terrorists isn't innocently minded no I
was nervous
it's [ __ ] on that um you sighs I read
one of my books okay yummy I trust you
so excuse me magic cafe get something
look I'm not have able through the smoke
grenade is that you yeah hey can I use
this
it's the quiet Nspire fight you don't
nobody get busy don't he's not dead
hey it must be one of you cuz he's dead
whoops
there we go okay I will wait kill me you
see I'm just really I'm sorry oh yes I
trust you next time I swear hi there I
thought I see I don't trust you ragoût
nice not so earned with lip it smart and
we got big actions you can act tonight
no no we did that no I heard that nope
nope nope nope
thank you aren't innocent I did I I
promise I mean I I am innocent but you
mean cetera actually you're probably
innocent too so what is the take you
innocent read out the text is about me
go screen right now where for what yeah
you are a nice you I wonder what it
yarn come isn't terrorist and it went
away sorry and then what what away what
you want from me
I can have my house this my hey hey I
have an idea I have an idea I have idea
everybody everybody if you want to
follow me there's a door we can go
through yeah so yeah okay yeah sounds a
bit suspiciously transistor this is
anyone on it does there's want to enter
the the nether portal cuz what's your
give candy I'm not going anywhere until
you tell me you have candy alright so
basically what we have to do is one at a
time we have to walk up to the corner of
this wall right here and we have to
press e on it and once we all go and
press E it'll open up okay so I'll go
first alright here we go
umm and all right there we go next
person next person I'm not going next
god
hey not here who's not here who's not
here already
yep it's yummy he's not here when Scott
Marshall its cow Moos gurgles what are
you doing why are you shooting me that
me that's the worst actually got I heard
in my life oh it wasn't I wasn't me I
don't know who to believe if you could
just be a little bit Higgy nicer ass who
that I was oh you dare don't you shoot
me I'm just staring out my pigs ass okay
oh that wasn't me my big shot you and
Roy Wow mark I said yeah good money he's
playing c4 down in the river we do you
if you if anyone walks through this door
there now guys full of uh uh baseball
bullets even that bullets
Wow who did I shoot sparkles oh I see
you and then I died I was in the room I
told you I was gonna shoot whoever go
into that room yes that's exactly what
it is tell us all about your player ways
yamimash I don't want to share my vast
knowledge you have to buy my book for
that we're only 3995 you can't approach
women today and I haven't seen another
person yet I saw you mr. sparkles ah
Oh what what's that sound
there's nothing alien nothing I heard
that nothing and that may have been a
traitor trying to dial it the traitor
hotline I know him go back out the
window are you sure you
yes right woody wait what are you doing
I'm a terrible cyber parable cyber going
how are you not dead
how are you know it you're both on one
hell night I'm a man / but I still got
you Yami Oh as far away to the cool
because the buildings got all these
rooms like so many rooms what ahh
why why'd you lock me in here makes as a
traitor sighs don't make some modest
stitches right now I think I over hey
you having a lot of fun I'm swinging out
yet is this is this the new like
exercising routine like cardio exercises
I could join in oh my gosh
I trust junkit nanny no I trust you I'm
sorry but have you come in this room I
will okay whoa
Yami misses a little tense all right
okay I know you're not the terrorist cuz
you just were wait a minute
yeah wait a minute very possibly am i it
I don't know the way you're looking at
me with that shotgun and I are you
trying to lead me so you can be alone
like me dream is mine if you coming down
you're a traitor
I'm um my computer put a certain me I'm
guys
whatever oh my god oh god that's
hilarious
oh no you were telling the truth I think
it's minx
hmm I think Oh No
oh my god why are you killing everyone
on say who's a terrorist remotely it was
carrying a person like him I was
carrying swath of body outside to be
fair with me that is a noise [ __ ] [ __ ] I
like it wait so is Biggs a terrorist or
what I'm dead
Oh your teeth dead oh we're dead Marcus
let you have another one 100 ohm okay
I liked your acting there by the way um
oh I really thought you were the
terrorist where where where's he's on
the ground for the belt okay all right
where's markiplier away from me
mark is arms it again come on I'm armed
with a gun rights era bottle you guys
are on different place oh he's outside
the building outside go outside feet
where is it great it's the straightest
second floor for you Americans huh
alright you guys are the same thing no
[ __ ] you using a Glock no I'm using a
deagle but then they're not even that
good
alright I'll deal with you let's Tegel
oh that's a Sun sexy know how to use the
c4 I was trying to get him in here so I
blow him up
I didn't know how to use it you press e
to arm or disarm oh I'm - boy ya heard
this all is there not to me twice now
that mark is just I think Joe's gonna
leave them in turn you all wish you had
this poker face I think it's mark and
Marty hey wait a minute don't you leave
me out here with this crazy bastard okay
so four of us handgun face hey let's do
a trust exercise put your guns on the
floor know what floor you're dying oh
wow so much shabby fun yummy wants to
show me don't shoot me to me don't shoot
me Oh Julie promised me oh you should
eat look at my eyes look in my eyes mark
what what's hello how you are not this
I'm another traitor
you know at least if you want to be safe
join me on the roof okay I'll tell me
other yo man let's go to the repo man
find me no I'm not wrap up
are you John Bayless dummy on your a
trait I trust you implicitly okay please
I framed
my Shyam Shyam and I'm late ha ha ha